my dreams settle down now I want to
share with you a high-level briefing
from top brass defense secretary
Gavin Williamson has come up with some
first-class ideas to ensure we can
continue to hone ourselves into a
ruthless well-oiled fighting machine
first our jolly jack tosser to get
clapped-out cross-channel fairies that
have been converted into warships and
the skies will have fleets of pop the
shelf drones he could have picked up
from Argos they're designed he says to
swarm all over enemy radar and to help
us fight them on the beaches our defense
secretary who used to be a quiet place
by the way reportedly wants to fit
tractors with guns and disguise missile
defense systems as soft drinks trucks
it's also keen to equip brave boys and
girls in Gibraltar with paint guns so
they can farm at Spanish vessels I'm
sure you'll agree troops these ideas are
sure to have the desired effect against
the risk is the Chinese the Iranians and
any other enemy they won't be able to
fight us they'll be falling about
laughing it's a strange one he's come up
with um in some of the strange ideas
he's come up with is Coca Cola lorries
to disguise be disguised as missile
defense and armed tractors yeah and it's
almost as if he's been watching too much
darkest hour you know like when when
they're actually use fishing boats
rescue people from the other side of the
channel and it was an ingenious plan and
it worked and it's almost as if he's
watched that and thought why don't we
reinvent that era which is kind of suits
your introduction there but it's all
kind of it is there's not a lot of votes
in defence is there so do you have a
government that says actually you know
what because the lunacy is he also
talked about the fact that when Queen
Elizabeth our aircraft carrier comes
into commission it will sail through the
South China Sea to effectively show that
you know the military path China has 11
aircraft carriers we start picking a
fight with China
we know where it's gonna go would you
ever sanction spending more money on
defense so that's the key magic and I'll
come around them well I think we are so
one of the good things is we are unlike
most of Europe meeting our NATO defense
targets right so I think we should keep
doing so I remember when I ran as a
liberal Democrat parliamentary candidate
back in 2015 which sounds like it feels
like a really long time ago even that
actually it wasn't but the debate was so
different because it was no Trump there
was no brexit and one of the things that
the the that particular political party
was going on about was basically getting
rid of trident and i nuclear deterrent
and I don't think anyone serious would
be suggesting it in today's climate
because now of course if you look like
Putin and the way he's reasserted
himself in the global stage and the way
he's now gonna pull out of as is Trump
pull out of the non-proliferation treaty
I think now if anyone suggests getting
rid of Trident and I need put in a fence
they'd be mad bonkers and so I'm happy
we are meeting our NATO defense spending
targets tonight yeah and we're meeting
that but that we're not fifth in the
world he claimed we're fifth in the
world well there is there is some doubt
about how you do it worries me China
Saudi Arabia and Russia are ahead of us
in defense spending which what I hear
from private Pike which is the nickname
given to our right honourable defense
secretary the right honourable Gavin
Williamson 42 is that he has he's
talking up in the country at a time when
the country has never looked more
diminished and at sea and the frankly
the truth is the whole world is not
sitting around and going wow as a former
foreign secretary said they are going
whoa you know because it's not looking
like we're in control and so therefore
we have to have Gavin willing Williamson
who talks a big game and I remember one
of the u.s. former Secretary of State
said the secret of defective diplomacy
and defense is speak softly and carry a
big stick and everything
Gavin Williams said about lethality and
swarms of drones and dressing up fairies
as battleships we shut up talking loudly
but carrying such as my dick what's
astounding a Britain Britain PLC in the
world
well I think this is part of the
promises I think it has a delusional
view of its position on the world stage
that's part of the problem but you're
right he's talking up a warning he said
there was a bizarre we said bricks it
has brought us to a great moment our
history and we must be ready to deploy
hard power now you know bricks at one
leg has got nothing to do with British
foreign policy at all but it hasn't but
has he forgotten the last time we went
to war over the floating of
international law jazz what are you
saying you know Iraq Afghanistan Libya
he's talking us into two wars that we
can't be part of and and you know if if
this government is serious about defense
the Tories have been steadfastly cutting
the defense budget for the last eight
years between 2010 and 2015 nine billion
pounds worth of cuts which is
effectively eighteen eighty percent the
budget Richard Dan it it was in charge
of the Arbitron poet said the Army is
only now half as capable as it was okay
June you wanted to take a few Carol and
the station of stature Britain yes I
think that we seem quite confused to the
world at the moment and I think Briggs
has got everything to do with our
foreign policy that's the whole point
we're leaving everything else and I just
want to add I think the funny thing with
Gavin Williamson is I mean fair enough
he's coming out with all of these
strange ideas but why are you telling
everybody what we're having here is Paul
responded to the scrap our poisonings
and Salisbury's it is absolutely
atrocious troche as' and outrageous what
Russia did in Salisbury we have
responded to that frankly Russia should
go away it should shut up but if they do
respond to what we the action that we've
taken we'll consider it carefully and
we'll look at our options
just one thing on brexit though if
breaks it does lead to the dissolution
of the United Kingdom the loss of
Scotland possibly honored
why would Britain maintain its seat on
the UN Security Council it will by no
means be the fifth largest power
rights respond from the minister if
they've said that the UK is one of only
four countries to meet the NATO 2% of
GDP defense spending target and is the
second largest spender behind the United
States in the last year alone we've
secured a further 1.8 billion pounds and
this week the Secretary of State
announced how a multimillion
transformation fund will be used to
ensure our armed forces meet the demands
of 21st century warfare and just briefly
I'll say one sentence the relationship
between brexit trade and and military
spending abroad is actually the Nexus of
it is trade most wars historically
started over trade and if if we have a
vision for trade after BRICS it then
it's it's inseparable to one minute and
my other problem with Gavin Williamson
is he is without a doubt the most boring
person on social media putting logs on
the fire we used to be a fireplace
salesmen yeah he did solve that one and
then finally eating ice cream this
country needs to defend it every defense
study that's ever been published says
all we need now is stuff to protect us
from technological warfare and robotic
warfare
everything else is superfluous and then
think about Gavin Wilson whose job in
his office is to to control the budget
last year the Public Accounts Committee
said that the budget was out of control
under him and that he's he's ordered
stuff any what he should be getting rid
of some of the vanity projects that
Cameron and Blair which he hasn't we
have to look at what we actually need
for this country this country has had no
threat from any armed force for 50-plus
years and and probably isn't like so I'm
not saying scrap our defenses but what
I'm saying is stop spending money on
stuff that we don't need if you come
back to Jun's point though as regards
Gavin Williamson imagine June and and
this is really where my heart goes out
and we probably could do with Phil
Campion he receives ex-military but
imagine you're a colonel in the SAS or
marine or your run of the men and women
who fly one of those tornadoes and
you're taking your orders ultimately we
always hear about morale can you imagine
whatever do for something like yeah and
that is extraordinary someone like that
giving away the trade secret sorry we've
gotta go from military spending I'm
afraid to spending on people coming up
next I'm saying we should all be giving
everyone more cash either Nick